nous commençons par jeu roman de michel
butor la modification michel buteur je
ne voyais pas le sujet de votre roman
parce que je crois que vous me fusiller
demeurer jour où j'ai peur en tout cas
que vous me disiez non je ne peux pas
vous raconter mon livre mais ce que je
voudrais c'est que vous dites ou même
dans quelle situation se trouve se
trouve votre personnage il est dans le
train et pourquoi était dans le point
qu'est ce qu'il fait dans ce train où va
ce train cetera
eh bien il est dans le train dans un
train qui va de paris à rome
il va à rome pour retrouver une femme
il est marié il est marié à une femme à
part il a des enfants nés marine mais il
a à rome une maîtresse et s'il fait ce
voyage c'est pour retrouver cette femme
cette femme qu'il veut dire qu'il a
trouvé pour elle une situation à paris
et pour lui demander de venir à paris
pour qu'ils vivent tous les deux
ensemble et se séparera de sa femme
légitime sans scandale du tout tout se
passera très bien
il a tout prévu et il vivra avec cette
femme romaine pour laquelle il enfin ces
timbres amendes qu'il aime beaucoup
bon ça c'est ce qui est décidé c'est la
raison pour laquelle il part pour rome
c'est cela c'est le projet qu'il a au
départ de son voyage c'est pour ça qu'il
va lorsque nous ouvrons la première page
de ce livre
ce personnage est déjà dans le trait
nous y sommes avec lui et lorsque le
roman sera terminé nous saurons ce sens
qu'il ya pas tellement entend tout cas
que nous aurons quitté ce train c'est
donc le récit de ce voyage que vous avez
fait et c'est en même temps
l'évolution de ce que ce personnage a
décidé de faire parce que pratiquement
lorsque le roman s'achèvera ce
personnage sera bien à rome et il ne
verra même pas cette femme pour laquelle
il y est allé
oui pendant son voyage le projet son
projet initial va se se détériorer
complètement au début du voyage du livre
et du voyage il part avec l'attention de
vivre trois jours à rome avec cette
femme
et puis de lui faire part de tous les
deux tout ce qu'il a prévu et une fois
arrivé à rome
eh bien ils s'apercevront il sera que
tout cela est absolument impossible
à tel point que pendant les trois jours
qu'il passera à rome il ne verra même
pas cette femme il n'ira même pas la
voir il ne la verra même pas bon je
pense que cette histoire telle que vous
venez de la raconter et la matière que
vous donnez à votre lecteur mais vous
demandez à votre lecteur beaucoup plus
que de suivre cette histoire lui
demander d'y participer car pendant la
durée du voyage sur 22 heures à peu près
un peu moins la zone 2 ce qui se passe
il ne se passe rien pour vous en parler
ce qui se passe c'est que ce personnage
change d'avis dirons nous oui c'est la
raison pour laquelle ils changent d'avis
n'ai pas eu une seule raison et une
raison très important ce sont des tout
petits détails parce que vous appelez
des micro-événements qu'ils font changer
la vie et le lecteur assiste à cette
mise en doute de cette décision que ce
personnage avait pris mais ils assistent
et ne comprend pas toujours très bien
pourquoi se dire que vous demandez aux
lecteurs en réalité d'acquérir peu à peu
au cours des pages les obsessions les
ennuis les petits agacements que votre
personnage a dans la tête lui déjà
depuis dix ans depuis cinq ans oui quand
vous dites que la transformation de ce
projet et n'a pas de raisons importantes
je ne crois pas que ce soit tout à fait
vrai oui il a des raisons importantes
les régions financent d'heure très très
très importante mais ce qui se passe
c'est que pendant le voyage il y a comme
vous dites des des micro événements qui
vont transformer la façon dont ce
personnage voit sa situation au début du
voyage
le personnage a une certaine image de
lui même et une certaine façon de voir
sa vie et puis peu à peu des événements
très minime
par exemple le fait que la façon dont
des gars vont passer dans la vitre du
compartiment les gestes que vont faire
les autres voyageurs
ces gens qui ne l'a jamais vu qu'il ne
qu'il ne reverra sans doute jamais vont
orienter peu à peu ses pensées de telle
sorte qu'il sera obligé de réviser
complètement la façon dont il voit sa
propre situation
mais si cela est possible si ces micro
événement amène une transformation aussi
énorme pour lui
et bien c'est parce que si vous voulez
il y à une bombe qui est monté alors il
suffira d'appuyer sur un interrupteur
comme pour une bombe atomique si vous
lui suffira d'un tout petit mouvement
pour provoquer une libération d'énergie
énorme pour provoquer une transformation
énorme chez ce personnage tout la façon
de voir les choses du personnage est en
quelque sorte miné il y a si vous voulez
dans le monde qui entoure ce personnage
des cavernes qui sont masqués par sa vie
quotidienne
est ce ce voile qu'il ya sur les choses
et bien il va se crever il si il n'avait
pas pris le train ce jour là s'il n'y
avait pas eu ces petits événements là
à l'intérieur du grand parti mans
peut-être que le voile aurait pu
subsister encore au moins un certain
temps alors évidemment la question la
question qu'on pourrait poser à ce
moment là c'est dans cette
dans ce second ensemble dans cette ces
raisons importantes qui sont derrière
les petites raisons qui vont amener à
dévoiler les raisons important alors
quelles sont elles et alors là encore
c'est que je crois que c'est très très
difficile à dire parce que il y a tout
un tout un échelonnement de raison il ya
d'abord des raisons personnelles il ya
des événements de sa vie qui vont lui
apparaître alors qu'il les avait oubliés
alors qu'il n'y pensait plus notamment
une scène une scène qui a eu lieu à
paris qui est une rencontre entre ces
deux femmes et cette rencontre il
l'avait oubliée et peu à peu il va
elle va lui réapparaître ainsi certains
événements de sa vie vont lui
réapparaître et vont transformer la
façon dont il voit les choses autour de
lui mais ça ne suffit pas parce que si
les petits événements du compartiment
autant d'importance c'est parce qu ils
se rattachent à des événements beaucoup
plus important pour lui à des choses
beaucoup plus importantes pour lui si
les événements de sa biographie on cette
importance c'est parce que et si
certaines scènes se révèle tout d'un
coup pour lui décisive c'est parce
qu'elles sont liées elles aussi à des
choses encore plus importante les
événements de de ses 22 heures sont
liées aux événements de toute sa vie
mais les événements de toute sa vie sont
liés à tous les évènements qui entourent
alors lis l'amour qu'il
les les amours si vous voulez qu'il a
pour ces deux femmes se se trouve lié à
ces deux villes paris et rome et dans la
façon dont il voit ses deux femmes dans
la façon dont se transforme ce qu'il
pense de ces deux femmes et les les
projets qu'il a vis-à-vis de ces deux
femmes se trouvent impliqués
non seulement ces deux femmes non
seulement lui
mais toutes les relations entre un
personnage de son genre de son espèce il
vous voulez et alors c'est énorme objet
c'est énorme personnages que sont par
exemple les villes de paris et de rome
avec tous secousse
tout ce que cela peut signifier j'arrive
aucune autre question à vous poser ou
gels huit ans lorsque je n'ai pas le
temps de le faire je l'aurais voulu dire
que lequel par vous quelle belle part
vous donner aux lecteurs vers le lecteur
est très actif votre niveau vous lui
donnez pas une histoire tout tout mâché
wingles c'est vrai le lecteur un rôle
important du hammam je crois que le
lecteur a toujours un trait rond un rôle
très important dans tous les livres
parce que c'est le lecteur qui lit alors
oui mais ce que j'aurai lire aussi c'est
juste juste ce dernier mot c'est que le
titre même de votre roman la
modification concerne aussi bien votre
personnage qui se trouve modifiée au
cours de ce voyage que le lecteur que
vous expliquez vous l'espérez sera
modifié un peu au moins pendant la
lecture de ce roman un mot je voudrais
qu'il soit pas simplement modifié
pendant l'allaitement il rappelait que
j'ai je suis beaucoup plus méchant que
ça envers le docteur oui que je veux je
voudrais qu'il soit week que quelque
chose soit modifiée dans la façon dont
les dans sa façon aussi à lui de voir ce
qu'il en sera
m